let's say we run an experiment to
determine if a reaction is endo or
exothermic
for our hypothetical reaction a reacts
with b to form c
and let's say this reaction takes place
in aqueous solution in a beaker
we can define our system as the
reactants and products that make up our
chemical reaction and everything else is
part of the surroundings for example the
water and also the beaker the reaction
is taking place in
let's say we run the reaction and we put
our hand on the beaker and we feel that
the beaker is warm if the beaker is warm
since the beaker is part of the
surroundings
energy must have been transferred from
the system to the surrounding so heat
flowed from the system to the
surroundings and that's an example of an
exothermic reaction so delta h is
negative
we can determine the amount of energy
that flowed from the system to the
surroundings by looking at the energy
profile for our hypothetical reaction
in an energy profile potential energy is
in the y-axis in kilojoules per mole and
reaction progress is on the x-axis so as
we move to the right on the x-axis the
reaction is occurring
our reactants which are a and b have a
certain amount of potential energy so
that's right here on our energy profile
so that part represents the energy of
our reactants our reactants react
together to form our product which is c
and that's at the very end so over here
this line represents the energy the
potential energy of our products
notice how the potential energy of our
reactants is higher than the potential
energy of the product so if we were to
find the change in energy
that would be the final minus the
initial so the energy of the products
minus the energy of the reactants for
this energy profile the energy of the
products is about 50 kilojoules per mole
and the potential energy of our
reactants is at 100 so this would be 50
minus 100 which is equal to
negative 50
kilojoules per mole
so on our energy profile we could show
delta e which would be this difference
right here so that represents delta e
and the change in energy delta e
is also equal to the change in the
enthalpy delta h for this reaction
so we know that the change in enthalpy
is equal to negative 50 kilojoules per
mole so let's go ahead and plug that in
over here on the left so by feeling the
outside of the beaker we knew that the
reaction was exothermic but the energy
profile allowed us to figure out how how
much energy was transferred from the
system to the surroundings
so for an energy profile when the energy
of the reactants is higher than the
energy of the products this is the
energy profile for an exothermic
reaction
let's say we ran a similar reaction
where a plus b turned into c but this
time when we felt the beaker the beaker
felt cool to the touch if that's the
case it's because energy was being
transferred from the surroundings to the
system and since the surroundings was
losing energy that's why the beaker felt
cool
so heat flowed from the surroundings to
the system and this occurs in an
endothermic reaction and the change in
enthalpy delta h is positive for an
endothermic process
when we look at the energy profile for
an endothermic reaction the energy of
the reactants let's go ahead and write
reactants in here the energy of the
reactants is lower than the energy of
the products
so this time if we find delta e
the that would be the energy of our
products minus the energy of our
reactants and the energy of our products
is about 100 kilojoules per mole
and the energy of our reactants is about
50 so let's say it's 100 minus 50 which
would be positive
50
kilojoules per mole
so on our diagram if we represent delta
e
that would be this difference here on
the energy profile and once again delta
e
is equal to the change in the enthalpy
delta h for the reaction
so delta h for this hypothetical
reaction is positive 50 kilojoules per
mole
since delta h is positive we know that
energy was transferred from the
surroundings to the system and that's
the reason why the products have a
higher potential energy than the
reactants in our energy diagram